president biden recently signed a brand
new executive order going and looking at
the digital asset industry what he said
was that the united states wants to be a
leader in the digital asset industry but
we want to make sure also that there's
no nefarious or illicit activity
happening this is a great sign because
what it does is it validates bitcoin
cryptocurrencies and blockchain
technology but of course there's been
many many politicians before the
president and the current administration
have been trying to get digital assets
build a regulatory framework and help to
make sure that this innovation creates
jobs and economic prosperity here in the
united states one of those individuals
is congressman tom emmer out of
minnesota and he's been pushing a ton of
legislative initiatives for it but
yesterday he had this great threat
looking at the executive order and
saying what the hell does this actually
mean for the industry and for the
average american citizen and so after he
went ahead and reviewed it he said that
as expected this executive order
directed various federal agencies to
study benefits and risks of digital
assets to the economy global
competitiveness and provide legislative
recommendations crypto tokenization
blockchain nft smart contracts and
stable coins are all powering a more
viable economic structure and as a
country it's imperative that we develop
a strategy to foster this innovation i
don't think very many people are going
to disagree with that but then emmer
went on to talk about the blockchain
caucus has been advancing a pro crypto
legislative and oversight agenda for the
past eight years this executive order is
eight years after we saw various
politicians go ahead and start to talk
about these things so ultimately what
ember talks about here is that some of
the findings of the executive order are
sound we have a national interest in
fostering digital asset innovation
that's true the rest of the executive
order focuses on consumer protection
systemic risk global competitiveness
international standards and placing
guardrails on code to make sure it's
resilient now let's go ahead and read
between the lines and ladies and
gentlemen this is where it gets nice and
spicy emmer said that decentralization
is the point which is right he gets it
the executive order doesn't mention
decentralization once big problem the
disintermediation of our economy will
enable all americans regardless of
circumstance to decide their futures not
a bank or big tech or the government
that's a principle that the united
states was built on and then he goes on
to say that given this administration's
regulatory posture towards the crypto
community we have no reason to assume
that the directives in the executive
order will yield results that
appropriately acknowledge the importance
of leading with digital asset policies
that prioritize open permissionless and
private technology very key important
things and so then he says that the
executive order places the highest
urgency on the agencies to study central
bank digital currencies any common sense
analysis of a potential central bank
digital currency that is not open
permissionless and private would
illuminate that the very idea is an
entire non-starter and a disservice to
americans kudos to tom ember because i
agree with him you have to have open
permissionless technology if you're
going to have true decentralized digital
currencies now he goes on and says that
most fortunately the executive order
doesn't ask the sec to weigh in sec
chair gensler has spent the past year
intimidating crypto innovators and
entrepreneurs with his unproductive
regulation with his unproductive
regulation by public statement
enforcement action his input is not
critical then tom emmer goes on and he
explains that overall it's critical that
we maintain tech and economic leadership
on the global stage and he looks forward
to continuing to work to find bipartisan
solutions to keep our great crypto
community right here in the united
states and so ultimately i think that
that's exactly what's at stake here is
that it's great that the president and
the current administration are saying
this technology is real this technology
is not going anywhere we want to be a
global leader and we need to make sure
that we understand all the nuances of
the industry in order to help foster it
as it grows but we have to be careful
that the government doesn't overreach
that they don't actually get in the way
they don't create more friction for
innovation and entrepreneurship
ultimately this technology is going to
be adopted globally and there's a
competition underway from nation states
from states from cities and local
jurisdictions where are the innovators
going to live work and build their
businesses where are the investors the
holders of these assets going to live
work and build their companies as well
that's what's at stake and the united
states wants to be a leader then we have
to simply create a framework and get the
hell out of the way let the innovators
innovate let the investors invest and
let the people do this because the
private sector is better suited to
actually foster this industry growing
and gaining that global adoption than
the government ever will be hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time